Salut ! Aujourd'hui je devais vous faire un tour parce que ont est mardi, le mardi je fais un tour à quelqu'un ... mais c'est un petit peu exceptionnel =)
Hier soir c'était la dernière des hallucinations collectives au théâtre. Y'en a pleins qui sont venus, merci à vous.
Philippe Roche était avec moi. Philippe Roche que vous avez déja vu dans des vidéos que je vous met là, là et là !
Alors moi malin, vous voyez comme ça comment ça se passe ... je me dis je vais garder Philippe Roche pour qu'il vous apprenne quelque chose.
Et ma demande Philippe aujourd'hui, en ta qualité, de chanteur/imitateur/ performeur vocal : Est-ce que tu peux nous apprendre à faire des voix ?
Quelques voix ?
Non !
Est ce que tu veux que je t'apprennes à faire des voix ? :D
Oui ça m’intéresserais !
Tu pourrais faire les chanteurs de variétés, les poètes, les slameurs ...
Comme j'ai la voix un peu grave et que vais être obligé de donner l'exemple pour faire voir que tu expliques bien je préfère plus ouai des mecs qui ont la voix un peu grave heu ...
Alors si tu veux faire un chanteur déjà la première chose c'est de prendre heu je dirais des ... des connaissances sur comment chanter mais très rapidement.
Faut que tu prennes le souffle par le bas comme ça.
Tu fais une belle inspiration avec ton ventre.
Tu appuie comme ça sur ton diaphragme et tu fait un HAAAAAA comme ça vite fait "HAAAAAaaaaa" , oui on a fait un apéro hier soir. Voila voila ça c'est ton foie.
J'avais tellement promis que je chanterais plus jamais sur cette chaine !
Je suis désolé je, il m'oblige !
Et en imitation bah c'est l'inverse !
Ce que je viens de te dire ça sert à rien.
Tient heu: Grand Corps Malade !
Comme les vieux imitateurs qui annonçait : " Et maintenant heu Grand Corps Malade"
Tu prends une posture.
Prenez la posture vous aussi =)
Tu as même la voix un petit peu plus grave que moi, tu vas essayer de me faire un "JE, JE", va chercher le son le plus grave que tu puisses faire.
"HEEEUU"
Ha oui tu es une vraie basse !
Tu imagines ensuite, et si tu l'as écouté au préalable il a forcément une façon de prononcer les phrases !
Une musique un peu ...
Une musique ! "Je voudrais porter un slam à toutes celles qui nous porte et nous aimes "
C'est Grand Corps Malade les mecs !!
"Cherche au fond de toi on a tous un point fort" ... et tu verras qu'en fait c'est toujours la même façon de prononcer les phrases.
A la fin il laisse traîner et il a une forte prononciation de certaines lettres.
Si je dois faire Grand Corps Malade, si on veut faire ensemble Grand Corps Malade ... On prend un peu une posture, je cherche à descendre du coup, je pense à sa musicalité : "TAKATAKATA"
Tu places ta voix !
C'est exactement comme dans le chant, tu places ta voix.
"TAKATAKATAKA" mais surtout le premier mot : "je voudrais porter un slam", et t'essaye le dernier mot de lui donner une intonation.
"SLAM" - voila- "Je voudrais porter un slam"
Et ça fait partie de ces voix alors je l'explique aussi dans mes vidéos, comme Maître Gims ou autre, il faut faire résonner les mots !
Les chanteurs utilisent souvent la technique d'avoir une sorte de coupole dans la bouche "pour faire résonner les mots".
Voila, bien, tu fais bien résonner les mots.
On dirait Raymond Barre. -Rire-
Faut un peu la bouche souple.
T'imagine toi même que ça résonne !
Je prend souvent l'exemple de Maïté, tout le monde sait faire : "Holala mais ..." et donc c'est à dire qu'a ce moment la tu es entrain d'être coperto, tu ouvres totalement ta voix.
Coperto he ho. "Mais dite donc" -accent Maïté- et tu fais ce trafic. Tu vas chercher les notes dans le nez aussi comme ça. Et à partir de ce moment là : "Je voudrais porter un slam à toutes celles qui nous porte et nous aime"
"Je voudrais porter un slam à toutes" -façon Maïté-
C'est ça ! Il suffit simplement d'appliquer toutes ces règles et de mettre de la résonance.
"Je voudrais porter un slam à toutes celles ... "
je suis désolé j'ai l'impression d'avoir une patate chaude dans la bouche.
Porte le son en avant: "Je voudrais porter un slam à toutes celles qui nous porte et nous aime"
"Je voudrais porter un slam à toutes celles qui nous porte et nous aime"
Bah on y arrive la =)
"Je voudrais porter un slam à cette grande dame que l'on appel Panam' "
Et ben voila ça y est tu vois tu y es !
PRAAAAAAH
Ca prend allez 5 minutes.
Pourquoi j'ai fait PRAAAAAH ?!
Essayez de le faire, en vrai c'est hyper interessant, j'ose plus le refaire ducoup, on va rester sur une bonne note !
J'ai une idée, tu me le dis hein si tu veux pas le faire on fait autre chose.
Si tu fais Grand Corps Malade pourquoi on ferais pas petit corps exité ?! Nicolas Sarkozy !
La tu me prend au dépourvu parce que je fait pas de voix parlées normalement.
Oui, écoute, applique tes propres conseils !
Oui appliquons, bah alors tient on va appliquer parce que je fait vraiment jamais de voix parlées. Tout à l'heure on parlait de Grand Corps Malade qui est assez raide, la on va avoir ce personnage, voila déja ...
Je me met dans le rôle !
T'as tout de suite envie de parler comme ça.
Oui ça donne envie de parler comme ça !!
et ben tu le tient bien !
C'est vrai qu'on a envie de ... de regarder un petit peu par en dessous comme ça.
Et tout les imitateurs de Laurent Gerra à Cantelou ont donné et bien à cette voix ou on en fait un générique !
Ce qui fait qu'on reconnait l'imitation en fait !
Bah totalement.
Et ce qui fait que quand vous allez faire Sarkozy la première chose que vous allez faire j'en suis sur vous allez avoir ce petit : "Bonjour, j'ai envie de vous dire, écoutez bien madame Chabot"
Tu vois il y a plein de petites phrases comme ça ...
"Moi je vais vous le dire ..."
Tout ça se sont les imitateurs qui vous l'ont mis en tête, c'est pour ça que dans notre monde d'imitateurs c'est assez compliqué quand une voix est générique de la reprendre derrière parce que on est obligé presque d'utiliser les codes qui nous ont été donnés.
Donc je pense que c'est pour ça qu'il faut être a peu près le premier sur une voix.
Et oui parce que c'est toi qui donne l'empreinte de la voix.
Et si t'es pas le premier bah il faut avoir la chance...
Comme avec Yves Lecoq à l'époque avec le ... tout les imitateurs faisaient le Chirac d'Yves Lecoq aux Guignols avec le "manger des pommes".
Et ce qui avait été très très grand de la part de Laurent Gerra, c'est que Yves Lecoq avait également le Johnny Hallyday le "ha que coucou" .... comment faire mieux ?
Et lui il était arrivé avec un vrai personnage qui commençait toujours par heu : " Bonjour c'est Johnny ".
Ha il avait trouvé son propre gimmick !
Ha oui c'était ce gimmick la et aujourd'hui refaire Johnny c'est refaire Laurent Gerra.
Ouai, et oui ! Tu fais Johnny toi ?
Non je fais Laurent Gerra ! -rire-
Heu je pensais à ce que tu me fasse Maître Gims !
... La maintenant ?
Je sais pourquoi il veut pas faire Maître Gims ! Il veut pas le faire parce que demain il lance sa chaîne Youtube officiellement ! T'es rentré dans le game =)
C'est ça ... j'ai les pétoches hein qu'est ce que tu veux ?!
Ho écoute avec tes 5 abonnés, il a 5 abonnés et il arrive à avoir 15 pouces en bas c'est énorme !
En fait ta première vidéo tu l'a fait quoi il y a 15 jours un trucs comme ça ?!
10 jours même pas ?!
Exact Ouai !
Et elle elle est déjà en ligne, bon on va dire c'est l'épisode zéro. Tu nous apprend à faire Maître Gims, ou y'a déjà le constat musical.
Il fait des constats musicAUX qui sont extrêmement drôle suivi à chaque fois d'un ou des fois en dissocié d'un tuto imitation ! Je trouve ça mortel comme concept !
Pouce en l'air !!!
Et j'éspere que quand tu seras au millions d'abonnés tu voudras encore faire des vidéos avec moi.
Mais bien sur !
Ho j'aime bien l'imitation le "ouiii oui oui oui oui"
Abonnez vous, il m'a fait voir les images c'est cool !
Merci pour les tutos, pour nos amis de la team mentalo !
Merci à vous d'avoir regarder cette vidéo, j’espère que ça vous aura plu ce petit truc un petit peu différent.
On avait fait un truc comme ça avec Zapata une fois et ben la c'était avec Philippe =)
Si ça vous a plu ce petit concept, c'est pas tout les jours mais si ça vous plait n'hésitez pas à me le faire savoir en mettant un ...
POUCE EN L'AIR !
Vous pouvez également commenter cette vidéo ou vous abonner en cliquant la haut ! Faite le c'est très important.
Et le mental vlog c'est une vidéo par jour pendant un an, rendez-vous demain à 17 h TCHAO :D